we're following developing news from
overnight five homes destroyed after a
fire yeah alex this morning several
people have now lost their home they're
staying in local shelters because of
what happened last night we have bianca
holmen live this morning near warm
springs in east lake mead
with the latest details bianca good
morning
good morning john good morning alex so
utility vehicles and trucks are here on
scene now
after the fire has been contained and
put out by the fire department so we
just saw
centurylink we saw southwest gas and
we've also seen envy energy here on
scene
kind of handling the utilities now we're
told that the fire started last night
around 11
and that it started in one mobile home
but it was the wind that caused the
flames to spread destroying at least
five other homes police clark county and
henderson fire departments rushed in to
rescue people it was a scary moment for
residents living in this neighborhood as
they sought shelter
across the street at an elementary
school
the police were very good the fire fire
department was very good to get us out
of here
they cut a hole in the fence for all of
us to get out in the desert area so
all we could do is say a prayer you know
saying and hope hopefully everything
works out
a matter of fact as that man was
speaking you could hear the wind really
whipping
as just an example of how strong those
winds were the fire
cause is under investigation but there
was a red cross
that was here and trying to help people
again who were displaced by this fire
again they sought shelter across the
street at the elementary
school and there's also a heritage
senior center right down the street here
where
residents can go to cool off during the
day again they were told coming
from the elementary school back to their
homes that the power could be out for up
to 48 hours so
just a very unfortunate situation the
night of father's day and waking up this
morning reporting live in the southeast
part of the valley bianca holman
8 news now